MONDAY.
♪ ♪
>> Hannity: AFTER REFUSING TO
COOPERATE WITH THE SHAM
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME A PERSON IS BEEN
FOUND GUILTY OF CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS CHARGES SINCE G GORDON
LIDDY IN 1974 THEY DIDN'T EVEN
PUT ON A DEFENSE TAKE NO BY THE
WAY IF YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN OR A
TRUMP SUPPORTER YES THE
ALL-POWERFUL JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE
WILL DRAG YOU TO COURT AND SEND
YOU TO JAIL IF YOU REFUSE TO
CATER TO THEIR EVERY WHIM.
THERE'S A LOT MORE BEHIND THIS
IF YOU ARE A CLINTON LAWYER YOU
GET ACCUSED CREDIBLY ALIGNED TO
THE FBI JURY OF CLINTON DONORS
THERE AND CLEAR OF ALL CHARGES
AND ARE TO GET AWAY SCOT-FREE OF
SHAREHOLDER AND OBSTRUCT JUSTICE
AND OBSTRUCT CONGRESS RATHER NO
CHARGES, NO JAIL TIME AND NO
FINE.
DON'T HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE OR
APPLICATION ON OR LOSS WILL LOOK
A LOT MORE TO THIS LATER IN THE
PROGRAM.
ALSO TONIGHT THAT'S A PRETTY
UNBELIEVABLE STORY OF A WOMAN
ASSUMING A MAN HE DIDN'T SHOW UP
FOR A DATE SHE IS SUING HIM AND
WHILE THE COURT PROCEEDING IS
GOING ON SHE GETS IN A HUGE
FIGHT WITH THE JUDGE.
HERE IS A PREVIEW.
>> YOU HAVE TO LAY.
YOU HAVE TO LAY YOUR COMPLAINT
OUT IF THE LEDGES IN THE
COMPLAINT.
YOU HAVE NOT.
>> Hannity: YOU'RE GONNA LOVE
THIS ENTIRE PLATE PLUS NEW YORK
REPORTER AND CANDIDATE LEE WILL
JOIN US IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
NOW LAST NIGHT THE G.O.P.
HOPEFUL AND SITTING CONGRESSMAN
WAS VICIOUSLY ATTACKED ONSTAGE
DURING A CAMPAIGN EVENT BY A MAN
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON WATCHES.
>> IS ONLY ONE --
>> YOU'RE DONE, YOU'RE DONE.
>> Hannity: THAT WEAPON
COULD'VE GONE RIGHT THROUGH HIS
HEART THANKFULLY HE WAS ABLE TO
GRAB THE ATTACKERS REST IT WAS
VERY QUICK MOVE ON HIS PART AND
PREVENT SERIOUS INJURY BEFORE
BEING PULLED TO THE GROUND
FOLLOWING THE INCIDENT
CONGRESSMAN ZELL THEN TWEETED
THE ATTACKERS WORDS AS HE TRIED
TO STAB ME A FEW HOURS AGO
YOU'RE DONE.
WITH SEVERAL ATTENDEES JUMP INTO
ACTION TACKLED THE GUY AS HE
CONTINUED.
THE ATTACKER WILL LIKELY BE
INSTANTLY RELEASED UNDER
NEW YORK'S LAW.
NOW ANYWAYS HE WAS RIGHT BECAUSE
SHORTLY AFTER THE PERPETRATOR
WAS ARRESTED HE WAS IMMEDIATELY
RELEASED FROM JAIL AFTER POSTING
$0 IN BAIL ON HIS OWN
RECOGNIZANCE, ZERO HE TRY TO
KILL A PUBLIC OFFICIAL SO ME GET
THIS STRAIGHT IN NEW YORK STATE
PERSON CAN ASSAULT A PUBLIC
FIGURE TRY TO KILL A CONGRESSMAN
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON IN THE
STATE IS MORE THAN HAPPY TO LET
THE ATTACKER WALTZED RIGHT OUT
OF JAIL NO BAIL ON THEIR OWN
RECOGNIZANCE THAT'S OKAY?
THIS IS SHAMEFUL AND IS
DANGEROUS NEW YORKERS YOU SHOULD
BE MORTIFIED EVEN WORSE KATHY
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THIS THIS IS
SET WELL WITH YOU A QUESTION IS
YOUR POLICY THAT YOU SUPPORT?
LAST NIGHT THE STATES FAR LESS
GOVERNOR PRETENDED TO BE
OUTRAGED BY THE ATTACKED ON
TWITTER BUT PRIOR TO THE ASSAULT
IT WAS HIS CAMPAIGN EMAILING HER
SUPPORTERS WITH EVERY LOCATION,
ALL THE DATES COME ALL THE TIMES
OF EVERY UPCOMING CAMPAIGN EVENT
AND SUGGESTED THAT THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE WAS AN
EXTREMIST.
EVEN TODAY, TODAY AFTER AN
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT HE HAD HER
STALKER SUPPORTERS FOLLOWING
HIM.
OF COURSE NOT BLAMING THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE ACTIONS OF
DERANGED INDIVIDUAL, BUT YOU
WOULD THINK THAT AFTER SUCH AN
ATTACK THAT MAY BE AND HER
FELLOW DEMOCRATS MIGHT NOT SEND
THEIR SUPPORTERS TO FOLLOW HIM
AND MAYBE START ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND
EXTREMISM IS COMING FROM THE
LEFT AND MAYBE THEY COULD
PUBLICLY DENOUNCE THE DOXXING,
THE STOCK INCOME OF THE
HARASSMENT THAT THEY ARE
INCENTIVIZING AND TELLING PEOPLE
WHERE TO GO.
REGARDLESS OF THE TARGETS
POLITICAL AFFILIATION.
THEY CAN STOP EXCUSING FOR
EXAMPLE ARSON, LOOTING,
VANDALISM, VIOLENCE AGAINST THE
POLICE, MAYBE WE CAN BRING BACK
BAIL LAWS IN NEW YORK STATE AND
FOR THE LOVE OF GOD YOU WOULD
THINK THEY COULD FINALLY START
PROSECUTING VIOLENT OFFENDERS
AND STOP LETTING THEM OUT OF
JAIL IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT BAIL
AND IT'S INTERESTING HE RELEASED
THIS AD YESTERDAY BEFORE THE
ATTACK EVEN TOOK PLACE.
>> TIME AND AGAIN PROTECTED
CRIMINALS AT THE EXPENSE OF
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
USING CASHLESS BAIL AND HIS OWN
FLAWLESS POLICIES.
PUT VIOLENT CRIMINALS BACK ON
THE STREETS AND HAS TURNED
NEIGHBORHOODS INTO DANGER ZONES.
AND WHERE IS KATHY HOPEFUL?
DESPITE THE PLEAS OF NEW YORKERS
SHE HAS REFUSED TO USE HER
AUTHORITY OF GOVERNOR TO FIRE
BACK.
>> NOT THE WORLD AT THE GOVERNOR
CAN MAKE THOSE LOCAL DECISIONS.
>> Hannity: BY THE WAY THAT
THE SAME D.A. THAT CHARGE THIS
GUY JOSE ALVA THE GUY WHO WAS
WORKING IN THE STORE THE BODEGA
WORKER AND THE GUY CAME AROUND
AND ASSAULTED HIM AND PUSHED HIM
TO THE GROUND.
THE START ATTACKING HIM DEFENDED
HIMSELF IN SELF-DEFENSE THEY PUT
THAT GUY IN RIKERS THEY CHARGED
HIM WITH SECOND-DEGREE MURDER
UNTIL THE PUBLIC OUTCRY GOT THE
CHARGES DROPPED.
EVERYONE IN NEW YORK AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY SADLY WHAT HAPPENED
TO LEE ZELDIN IS NOT UNCOMMON IN
THE PAST DECADE DOZENS OF G.O.P.
LAWMAKERS HAVE BEEN ASSAULTED
INCLUDING SENATOR RON PAUL WILL
ALSO JOIN US IN A MOMENT.
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE WE
KNOW WAS SHOT BY DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVISTS.
HE NEARLY DIED IN THAT SHOOTING
IN JUNE A MAN ARMED WITH A GUN
SHOWED UP TO JUSTICE KAVANAUGH
FRONT DOOR WITH PLANS TO
ASSASSINATE HIM.
AND BY THE WAY SINCE MAY 59
PRO-LIFE PREGNANCY CENTERS HAVE
BEEN ATTACKED, VANDALIZED OR LIT
ON FIRE.
BY THE WAY AS A RELATES THE
SPRING COURT JUSTICES THEY ARE
STILL DOXXING THESE JUSTICES
THEY ARE STILL SHOWING UP ON
THEIR HOMES EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
A LAW U.S. CODE 18, 15 OH SEVEN
SAYS YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GO TO
RESIDENTS OF THE JUSTICE OR
COURT OFFICER OR JURIST IN ANY
WAY WITH WORK.
WHY ISN'T SHE ENFORCING THAT
LAWLESS AND FORGET ABOUT THE FAR
LEFT RIOTS ALSO IN THE SUMMER OF
2020.
WE LOST THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS,
THOUSANDS OF POLICE OFFICERS
INJURED.
BILLIONS IN PROPERTY DAMAGE
INSTEAD OF CONDEMNING THE
SABBATH VIOLENCE WELL WE HAD
SOME TOP DEMOCRATS LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE MAXINE WATERS SHE WAS
TELLING HER SUPPORTERS TO HARASS
REPUBLICANS AND THE PUBLIC
KAMALA HARRIS PROMOTING THAT
BAIL FUND FOR VIOLENT WRITERS
AFTER THE POLICE PRECINCT WAS
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
THEY SAID THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA
STOP AND THEY SHOULDN'T STOP
TAKE KNOW TO BE AWARE.
>> Vice President Harris: THIS
IS A MOVEMENT I'M TELLING YOU.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA STOP.
EVERYONE BE AWARE.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA STOP THEY'RE
NOT GONNA STOP BEFORE
ELECTION DAY IN NOVEMBER AND THE
RACK AND A AFTER ELECTION DAY.
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD TAKE NOTE
OF THAT ON BOTH LEVELS.
THEY ARE NOT GONNA LET UP AND
THEY SHOULD NOT.
AND WE SHOULD NOT.
>> Hannity: TAKE NOTE AND BE
AWARE THEY ARE NOT GONNA LET UP
AND THEY SHOULDN'T LET UP.
CHUCK SCHUMER GOES TO THE STEPS
OF THE U.S. SUPREME COURT AND
THREATENS TO SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES BY NAME.
CAVANAUGH OUTSIDE THE
SUPREME COURT.
ANYTHING HAPPENED TO HIM TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU I WANT TO
TELL YOU CAVANAUGH YOU HAVE
RELEASED THE WHIRLWIND AND YOU
WILL PAY THE PRICE.
>> Hannity: YOU WON'T KNOW
WHAT HIT YOU.
SO DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO FIGURE
THE VIOLENT BEHAVIOR WHAT
HAPPENED IN NEW YORK LAST NIGHT
WHAT IS THAT GONNA BE A DAILY OR
WEEKLY OR MONTHLY OCCURRENCE AT
EVERY LIBERAL STATE AND CITY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY?